this outie r8 has a sound like no other
an actual fact that's because it's
lacking something very common in modern
sports car engines a turbocharger
this car has a naturally aspirated
engine explains line hood
he describes the bubbling hissing
cracking and howling they make but
they're a dying breed manufacturers
including Ferrari and Porsche use
turbocharged engines these days but only
a naturally aspirated engine creates
this sound the 5.2 liter engine sucks in
air and then pelts it back out at full
volume through the blade wheels which
are incidentally turbocharged but even
though the audi v10 engine isn't
turbocharged it puts out a serious 397
kilowatts of power music to the ears of
car fanatics maybe but if you're
concerned about co2 emissions these will
send shivers down your spine
it gives you a brand new hairstyle the
line who loves driving with the top down
the soft top and the r8 v10 spyder
weighs just forty four kilograms and
opens and closes in 20 seconds you can
also do this while driving at speeds of
up to 50 kilometers an hour
I know points out where that infamous
sound comes from behind the back
windscreen lower it to feel the full
force
the r8 convertible model weighs just 80
kilograms more than the coupe a thanks
to its consistent lightweight design
magnesium structures in the folding
mechanism help bring the weight down
extra panels on the aluminum space frame
provides sturdiness when the roof is
down the r8 engine sits between the two
axles for better weight distribution hot
air is expelled through the back of the
car the engine gets its fresh air
through the side optional extras include
laser lights and ceramic brake discs
vinyl describes a new RH more athletic
angular style and the lower single frame
radiator grille it's also three point
six centimetres wider so watch out he
says when driving through roadworks on
the highway some lanes are only 2 metres
wide
the new r8 Spyder is 1 metre 94 not much
room to play with so avoid overtaking
there's little space for luggage in the
front but it's just 112 litres r8 owners
are better off sending their luggage
ahead in the post other sports cars
outperform on that point
individually I know thinks customization
is also important in sports cars for the
first time the r8 Spyder comes with side
blades you can pick the color and even
put a logo or lettering on them so
whatever you call your car Kevin Shanta
you can display the name loud and proud
the r8 Spyder features the Quattro
all-wheel drive system the seven gear
transmission sits behind the engine to
drive shafts go to the back wheels and
one goes to the front axle an
electrically controlled multi-plate
clutch regulates the power supplied to
the front the inside almost feels like
the cockpit of a racecar decked out in
leather of course there are all the
usual conveniences like automatic
climate control you can also add the
Bang & Olufsen sound system with
headrest speakers in the age of
downsizing this 5.2 liter naturally
aspirated engine goes against the grain
somewhat they tend to consume more fuel
than turbocharged engines consumption
has apparently dropped 12% thanks to
cylinder deactivation the start/stop
system and reduce weight but if you're
heavy on the gas pedal you're looking at
15 to 16 litres per 100 kilometers and
the price of the new r8 v10 spyder has
risen to about 180 thousand euros in
Germany but that's the price you pay for
a naturally aspirated engine
kurtis Terenas Petri will be trying out
one of the best-selling electric cars in
europe than this on leaf she wants to
see how it handles in a variety of
typical driving situations Nissan has
just given the leaf a new battery that
increases range it's supposed to make
some 250 kilometres under ideal
conditions
but even after charging overnight we
only clocked around 200 kilometers the
electric motor puts out edie kilowatts
of power and blows the leaf up to a
maximum speed of 144 km/h but the
maximum torque of 254 Newton meters from
a standing start makes driving this
five-seat electoral power pack really
fun that leaves from 0 to 50 km/h in
just 3.7 seconds
enos points out that the driver can
extend the range with an efficient
driving style as well as the right
driving mode added to the normal drive
mode as the B mode which bumps up the
recuperation of energy from braking and
there's the Eco mode it cuts down the
power consumption of the electronics
saving juice for the motor once you've
gotten accustomed to the car seeming to
break whenever you let off the
accelerator driving the leaf quickly
becomes second nature
yes according to eNOS the leaf proves
its advantages as an electric vehicle
when in town where the constant back and
forth between accelerating and braking
recuperates energy and maximizes the
range so in Eco mode the leaf can
actually cover more kilometers in town
than its range display indicates but on
the highway it's a different story
eNOS discovers that the highway tends to
suck the Leafs batteries dry
there is no recuperation phase at all
it's a steady drain on the battery so
you can just watch the charge Abbe away
and the range along with it but highway
driving covers lots of kilometres in a
short time so to the Leafs credit we
should point out that the kilometers
driven actually correspond very closely
to the reduction in range indicated
name that aside from the range eNOS is
of course interested in what and whom
the car will carry she has a look in the
Leafs trunk
the first thing she notices is the deep
floor that's made possible by placing
the batteries under the seats then she
notices the equipment that comes with
the car the charging cable is standard
in every leaf and there's still room for
a whole suitcase and some shopping bags
on top the leaf was not intended for
long trips jam-packed with luggage but
almost everyone has to transport a
bigger load now and that the back seat
can be folded down in two halves making
room for two large bags side by side but
the folded down seats leave a step that
can get in the way and make it hard to
secure luggage
in Germany there's a government subsidy
for electric cars to provide an extra
incentive once this is subtracted the
leaf version we tested starts at about
thirty-two thousand euros in the
backseats eNOS has nothing to gripe
about they're very comfortable the front
seat is adjusted to fit her and in back
she still got plenty of room for her
knees and for her head above that's her
test drive of the Nissan Leaf over for
now
she gets the impression that the range
can vary widely according to the driving
situation but it's not a big deal after
all a range of 200 kilometers ought to
provide enough leeway to recharge
the concept ex class is mercedes-benz
vans sneak preview of its new pickup
truck the two variants powerful
adventure and stylish explore are meant
to combine the best of two worlds a
robust and practical workhorse on the
one hand but a comfortable urban
lifestyle and family car on the other
the body design is characteristic of the
brand the mercedes-benz x class is
slated to hit european showroom floors
in late 2017 the second generation
Cooper countryman is to be minis first
plug-in hybrid model the SC all four has
a range officially rated at 40
kilometers on batteries alone the new
countryman is 20 centimetres longer the
wheelbase 2 is 7 and a half centimetres
longer that makes for more space in the
rear it's due on the market in February
2017 at a starting price of 26 thousand
five hundred euros in Germany
the mercy bees a250 is the most powerful
standard 8 class we're testing the a250
sport model with all-wheel drive and 7
geared dual clutch transmission mercedes
calls it 4matic along with a special
diamond grill the sports package also
includes sporty upgrades to the body
engine and gearbox
that's awesome in terms of performance
and technology car tester Ronnie thinks
the Mercedes really has pulled it off
he's using the comfort mode but if you
want it really sporty and he means
really press the dynamic select button
it totally changes the car the
turbocharger reacts much earlier at
around 2,000 revs the steering is much
tighter than in comfort mode and the
throttle response is snappier the two
modes give Ronnie two completely
different driving experiences sport mode
also makes you drive faster than you
need to which uses more fuel but as
Ronnie points out that might be of
little concern to the typical Mercedes
customer a 6 gear manual transmission
model with front-wheel drive is
available for around forty four hundred
euros less the a250 sport 4matic starts
at about forty one thousand euros in
Germany that gets you a one hundred
sixty kilowatt four-cylinder turbo
engine that leaps from zero to 100
kilometres an hour and just over six
seconds the total fuel consumption is
about six point seven liters per 100
kilometers along with the technical
optimizations the sports package offers
aesthetic enhancements complementing the
diamond grill our red accents on front
and rear spoilers
alloy rims and five-spoke design red
brake callipers and perforated brake
discs
then John when Ronnie thinks back to the
first a class he never would have
considered buying it because the look
never appealed to him - luck if he isn't
and even if this interior were built
into the old model he still doesn't
think it would work because it looks so
sporty it's exactly what he looks for in
a sporty compact I've bought this with
no contravention there are round
instruments with coordinated red accents
the leather 3 spoke sports steering
wheel is a real eye-catcher
the car sportiness is set off by the
carbon gray cockpit and stainless steel
pedals with rubber studs red contrast
stitching and decorative elements fill
the interior
the control unit for the multimedia
system is neat and user-friendly but a
retractable display would improve the
overall image
no I compared to the old a-class Ronnie
thinks this new model is a revolution he
regards the a250 behind him as a little
brother to the a45 AMG except it isn't
an AMG by a longshot but he thinks the
car is fun and dynamic and with 160
kilowatts of power all-wheel drive and a
2-liter turbocharged engine is perfectly
suited to his tastes
i mukesh Walter says a little this
a-class is a little powerhouse with its
add-on sports package mercedes is
targeting a younger market but it begs
the question how many young people can
afford a car for 41 thousand euros or
won't one for that matter
nowadays SUVs come in compact or even
many sizes but the true original reps
and this class are the burly brutes cars
that could almost be considered off
rotors including the VW Touareg v6 TDI
manual is testing the 3 liter diesel
model with 193 kilowatts that's 262
horsepower it has an 8 gear automatic
transmission and despite its relatively
heavy 2.2 tonnes it has no problem
getting up to speed
this models fuel consumption is rated at
around 7 litres of diesel per 100
kilometers and moves from zero to one
hundred and seven point six seconds of
course it's not the NIP East but that's
hardly that Turing's forte this car is
all about comfort and space
the sure Nam the nice thing about the VW
Touareg says Amano L is the roommate
interior there's so much space that you
never feel cramped the car is relatively
wide which gives you lots of space on
the inside
despite the wider than average center
console in terms of workmanship
emanuelle doesn't have much to say
it's a typical VW top-quality these lb2
besides a full knieval this is what a
sporty car should look like with its
Arline interior the Touareg looks and
feels athletic and the he-double
multifunction leather steering wheel
with shift paddles adds to that emmanuel
has taken a seat in the rear having put
the driver's seat as far back as it can
go and even then he has four fingers of
legroom between his knees and the seat
that's quite remarkable but he mono was
wondering if the extra legroom comes at
the expense of cargo space the car
weighs 2.2 tons but he says you can pack
in another 700 kilograms including
passengers and there's no need to worry
plenty of space for luggage back here
the online exterior is sleek and sporty
with black high-gloss trim and two
chrome-plated angular tailpipes the rear
spoiler the wider rocker panels and
front and rear bumpers give it extra
athletic style
the 3-liter TDI runs so smoothly and
quietly to the untrained ear it might
even sound like a gasoline engine
sowhat's amanda was conclusion all in
all he's quite impressed with the
Touareg it's really spacious really
comfortable and sufficiently powerful
the only thing is a car this good can
only mean one thing money the turret
will cost you a pretty penny or two one
Shawna's no decline get her hot tub ohms
this year mind to work coffins occur
tucked away in a little village is the
177 year old for Wolfe Manor Elizabeth
Haysom uncle's parents ran a farm here
for many years she grew up on it
now at age 51 she not only takes loving
care of the manor but also of her
darling in the barn a Renault r4 that
she's nicknamed Madame beige
Elisabet explains that it's a renault
fahza or an r4 super from spain renault
used to have a plant in spain called
fahza
where they built this car now the model
has become quite a rarity and said no no
the first test runs commenced in 1959
for the prototype r4 known at the time
only as project 112 Renault produced the
compact its first car with front-wheel
drive from 1961 to 1990 to more than 8
million of them in the course of those
31 years
Elizabeth's r4 is from 1970 she'd gone
looking for it in fact she'd never
forgotten it
her love affair with this model began
here over 30 years ago
Elizabeth remembers they had one on the
farm they had a nice car but their field
car as they called it was always in r4
when I gave up the ghost they got
another one she learned how to drive in
an r4 at age 15 John Bolton videos from
Amalfi ofon Elisabet shows us the road
she took to the fields she used to help
her mother by taking lunch out to the
men but as long as she was under 18 she
had to stick the dirt roads the family
still owns the land it's not far away
from the manor her mother DRO till they
got to the field then Elizabeth took the
wheel and her mother walked back to the
house now
Elizabeth drives her very own dearly
loved r4 but not in the fields
you have a shoe my desk she tells us she
used to bring the food out to the fields
in a basket her mother had packed the
men would sit in the back and eat she
recalls once when they were planting
beets it was the Easter holiday so she
hung this Easter Egg on the side mr.
isayama
when the men had finished eating
Elizabet would pack up and head back but
she had to stop at the public road lock
up the car walk back to the house and
give her mother the keys that was her
daily chore now of course Elizabeth can
drive wherever she wants she started
driving Renault r4s as a teenager but
the first one she bought on her own
didn't last long
yes Elizabet explains that her first car
fell victim to rust she had just
finished her studies and wanted to spend
some time abroad but she didn't want to
give her brother and sister the car she
parked it in her grandparents garage and
left for Canada when she came back and
opened the garage door it was rushed and
through and through it hadn't been moved
and it wasn't the only r4 to be claimed
by rust the models arch-nemesis but
Elizabeth never forgot her old r4 so in
2010 she went out and bought her madam
beige but it wasn't as simple as paying
the purchase price the car was shiny
bright outside but riddled with bugs
inside she only noticed them after she
got the car home
so Elizabeth had to put lots of work
into restoring her new r4 but it only
brought her and madam beige closer
together recently they joined a group in
France
the vine more than or father she
recounts that they were all driving
Reno's and she was there with Madame
beige they spent the night at an old
mill she started talking to the hostess
but told her she'd acquired an old r4
together with the mill it was hidden
under some bushes somewhere he's a bit
asked what she intended to do with it
and the hostess gave it to her Elizabeth
got a Renault smack a nice outfit from
someone in the group and borrowed the
hostess foods from the mill she waded
into the BlackBerry brambles there she
found a beautiful old r4 that still had
its chrome trim she worked on it for an
hour and a half I'm screwing all the
chrome parts she could get she was
overjoyed that she could have so much
fun with her own car she has fun driving
it even if it isn't that fast still
gives her dependently from A to B even
if the radio crackles but she can live
with that toy for an appeal once the
smell totally Gardens hide you cannot
touch doesn't listen call her current
are four stands in the same barn the
first one did so long ago but it's
advanced from work car to Sunday car and
Elizabeth won't lose this one to rust
not if she can help it